what began as a response to the small
boats crisis has now become entrenched
and needs to stop so says the chief
executive of leading child rights
charity ekpat among a hundred
organizations calling on the government
to stop putting unaccompanied underage
Asylum Seekers at risk in government-run
hotels we already know that these
children are at higher risk of going
missing and we already know that they
you know they're vulnerable because they
are so um alone and arrive many of them
traumatized they've had terrible
Journeys
and not least that some of them may have
been trafficked into the country and
then it's easy for traffickers to pick
them back up again
following a surge in small boat arrivals
across the English Channel in 2021 it's
estimated that 600 unaccompanied
children have passed through this
Brighton Hotel being run by the home
office they're free to come and go and
official data reveals that 136 have been
reported missing more than half of those
are still unaccounted for
workers are prohibited from speaking out
but at another hotel a whistleblower has
said an estimated 10 percent of underage
occupants disappear each week the SE is
horrific Mr Speaker vulnerable children
are being dumped by the home office
scores of them are going missing and I
can tell the minister there is nothing
specialist about these hotels we are not
in response the government admitted that
to date 200 miners are still missing 13
of them under 16. and local activists
accuse the government of an ongoing
failure to protect Asylum Seekers
especially children often they get taken
into
um like running drug lines like
um
household like servitude Car Wash
um built like working on building sites
and I think a lot of the time they're
offered like a home education a job and
they're in a place where they feel
hopeless and unsupported I mean it's
very telling that children are leaving
to go away with traffickers instead of
saying saving in a hotel that's supposed
to be a safe space for them once they've
arrived
Sussex police the force responsible for
this area says that the vast majority of
these young people have no known
connection to anyone in the country very
little money and sometimes no mobile
phone meaning that very few lines of
inquiry are available in trying to
locate them
this the first of several planned
protests against the housing of
unaccompanied minors in government-run
hotels the Prime Minister Rishi sunak
has called for an end to the practice he
blames pressure on the migration system
something the government he says is
determined to resolve Jonah Al Jazeera
Brighton